but will smith said this to me he came
up to piss next to me and i got gun shy
because he has a huge [ __ ] and he has a
fire hose of urine coming out and he's
just pissing next to me and he's going
let me tell you the key to hollywood
umber chrysler i'm here to answer the
internet should you lock a dog out of a
room while you're having sex yes
especially if it's a bull mastiff
i was having sex with my wife one time
doggy style i thought he'd appreciate it
and
and i
you know like we're older and we
miscalculated height and i popped out
and my dog saw my dick and was like what
is that
and it's got all those pheromones on it
and the dog's chasing it and i'm
fighting this [ __ ] thing i got this
130 pound beast on the bed i'm fighting
the dog just kidding
if you could make your dick as big as
you wanted but for every inch you'd lose
two years off your life how big would
you make it
i'm not sure i have the two to lose
i am partying uh
i would put
i would put one more inch on my dick
so like one more stuff i take two years
off i put one more inch on my dick
because that inch is that i think if
you're gonna break your dick that extra
inch is like going from six one to six
two one yeah dude
there's a huge difference between a guy
that's six one and six two yeah i
watched a guy that was six four talked
to a guy that was six one and the guy
that six one didn't realize he was
shorter they were in chairs and the guy
at six one's like you're not bigger than
me and he got in his [ __ ] feelings
about it the guy's like i'm three inches
bigger than you yeah that's it that's a
yeah yeah uh no i would take well how
about this i would take i would add two
more inches off take four more years out
of my life but i would let my wife know
listen we're gonna have to separate in
like four years because i'm gonna run
this dick
what is a little thing
someone can do that automatically makes
them a crazy person bleed from the face
if you pick a scab off
if whenever you bleed on your face like
if you have a scab on your nose and it
starts bleeding you look crazy as [ __ ] i
still didn't answer and you had that
right
because it happened to me in a meeting i
had a scab i didn't realize it was scab
and we're in a general pitch meeting and
i was itching it and all of a sudden
someone's like
it's really scary they're like dude
you're bleeding and i was like huh and
they're like no you're like legit
bleeding and it dripped on my shirt and
i was like oh [ __ ] and they're like dude
like okay he's bleeding what's going on
i'm on blood thinners because i you know
i take i take baby aspirin so and i'm
like oh and i couldn't get it to stop
and everyone's like do you need to go
home and i was like no i'm fine they're
like why are you bleeding and i was like
i have a thing
the thing is propecia
if you had to watch your biggest enemy
[ __ ] the girl of your dreams in order
in order to in order
[Laughter]
someone didn't read a lot
in order to marry her would you do it
you know what's so funny
there was a minute
where i thought a guy
who i i like by
but
i don't like enough i thought he [ __ ]
my wife
there's a minute there was a second he
was playing a joke on me
if he knows he says he knows who he is
and if you do the research you can find
out who this is
and uh
i melted down and i thought to myself
do i still feel the same way about her
if i know she [ __ ] that guy right
and my answer was no
[Laughter]
my answer was no
and i just
and i was like what does this mean about
me and and i started spinning i get spin
out of control and i started spinning
out of control and then it turns out she
definitely never [ __ ] him thank god
thank god
yeah yeah yeah hard no hard [ __ ] no
would you rather give the first 99
percent
or the last one of a [ __ ] i just have
a joke about this but my joke was uh
would you rather be the starting pitcher
and throw eight innings or would you
rather just come in and take the load
right because on the one hand you know
on the low but also like that that's a
lot of work those first nine minutes or
whatever and the pitch was me and you
are in prison nine guys come in they're
like all right pick which one you want
to be starting pitcher or the catcher
you just or the or the closer they call
you and you take load and
every time someone would i'd ask someone
they'd go ah i go you're hesitating i'm
the starting pitcher and you're gonna be
like lucy in the chocolate factory
i heard the funniest [ __ ] joke by the
way uh because it reminded me of this
this guy told me on set as a british guy
he goes uh if you tell me if you've
heard this just stop me if you've heard
this he goes uh
guy goes to prison first night he's a
british guy still doing a british accent
he goes guy goes to prison first night
goes in
meets his cellmate big bloke big hairy
bloke and he goes all right here's how
it's going to work
we play a little game called mommy and
daddy on the first night
you got to pick which one you want to be
guy goes i don't want to be either he
goes no
you got to pick one mommy or daddy which
one is it and he goes
oh
obviously i want to be daddy and he goes
okay your daddy now come on over here
and suck mommy's [ __ ]
so the brazil german guy goes german guy
goes ein we have van very similar
he goes that guy comes into prison and
he says meet his roommate big big big
guy uh roommate and he says um
okay it's gonna happen whether you like
it or not you can do it with spit or
without spit and the guy goes i don't
want to do it at all he goes with spit
or without spit it's happening the guy
goes well clearly i want spit and he
goes okay hey spit he wants you too
shout out to phil and robert
if someone texted you a picture of your
dick with no context would you know it
was your dick yes
yes yes you know in a game we played one
time we had our wives come into a radio
station and feel our dick and balls
through a curtain and they had to guess
which ones was which and they nailed it
really not only did they nail it
cowhead's wife amanda felt my dick and
balls and go this is burnt
i swear to god
i swear to god
what a woman yeah what a pair of balls
if you had one time
passed what crime would you commit
i probably like a pass
it's got to be a bank robbery
like just like yeah like you just to see
if you could do it
like that hijack a plane
see if i can get the job
or something kidnap somebody
we're gonna get out
give me a deal
he is so kidnappable
you're like hey man we got a bag of
hamsters in this van he's like
this [ __ ]
gang gang son
get me some of them hamsters
he's like how why are you guys all
wearing gloves is it cold out i didn't
bring no gloves for me wait why is this
y'all being so rough is this a wrestling
van if you could live anyone's life in
their body who would you be
that's in my wife's life in her body
yeah i would [ __ ] molest it i would
i would come in she would be in my body
i would be in her body and then i'd come
up to her and go um i think we have a
problem she's like what did you put in
your vagina i go everything
i just want to see how big i can i saw a
baby come out of there
and i got some stuff stuck up there
i would definitely go i'd take my wife's
body and i would [ __ ]
destroy it would you rather give up
porn or sex for one year
well i've definitely given up sex for
one year before it's not as hard as it
sounds
yeah yeah uh this is called
up to being 18 years old
and by the way hold on and i've also
even when i was single i definitely won
a year without i went so long without
[ __ ] someone
that when i first had sex with my wife
i it felt awkward to have someone in the
room when i had an orgasm
like i was like i don't normally do this
with people
and i remember being like i remember
like oh [ __ ] like i'm normally i just
have an orgasm when i roll over go to
sleep and then i was like oh if you want
you can we will watch history channel
[Laughter]
i give up porn though i should stop
watching porn
would you rather [ __ ] a chick who banged
a thousand dudes or a chick who banged
one
what's the animal
one animal
um it's gotta be a dog yeah yeah
was it an accident
like did she come home
pass out with a thing of peanut butter
naked and then the dog just ended up
[ __ ] her dog [ __ ] you or did you [ __ ]
the dog yeah cause i've been [ __ ] by a
dog but
look i don't respect anyone who didn't
get [ __ ] by a dog as a kid
you if you didn't get [ __ ] by a dog as
a kid then you don't have good friends
where they [ __ ] hold you down like
get him rodeo and rodeo's just saw him
punch you and you're like this isn't
funny
by the way that's a true story a real
dog's name and and and yeah my buddy
caiman's gonna be like that was my dog
final answer though finally uh oh
a thousand dudes
yeah yeah because yeah because there's a
yeah but what do you think the over
under on like uh like uh
like a porn star is like what do you
think their number is it's gotta be like
i think those i think for when i was
reading an article once that for women
the number is surprisingly low
because there's so much
yeah so it's like it's like five dudes
they all [ __ ] you know what's so funny
is that a girl can do porn
for just like a month and then she's a
porn star forever yeah like
where's khalifa where's khalifa she was
only in like
her music
mia khalifa was only in like porn for
like a week yeah a week and then
everyone knows her as that and she's
more than that she's like really into
sports and [ __ ] but uh we i just talked
about this someone like christy mack was
only in porn for like a year and a half
she's like 19 i think lana rose did one
year i think eight months and she's the
number one person in porno i'm still
she's she's like the number one ranking
i wish that worked with stand-up yeah
yeah it's like no i did like four open
mics and now i'm the greatest comic
that's ever lived can you still go
to your barber if he's very racist
assuming this is not meant for a white
guy
[Laughter]
i don't i actually don't have a problem
with it at all actually don't talk to
him much
[Laughter]
sure
i actually think i might get a tighter
cut
what are the hardest things to do
casually what are the hardest things to
do casually like the the
hardest uh
everyday
like thanks right like jerk off like
[Laughter]
so uh what did you do this weekend
what are the hardest things to do
casually
uh snort coke
it's hard to do casually
it always turns into an event you're
like oh [ __ ] we're gonna do this [ __ ]
yeah and then you're like and no one's
like no one's like oh it's coke okay
[Laughter]
would you rather have your own personal
bathroom or your own personal office
i have both i don't think i understand
the question
[Laughter]
okay okay okay this is if i worked in
like cubicles sure yeah
i'd have my own personal office
office of a bathroom yeah like i take an
office over back because i like [ __ ]
in public like i am more i got like this
is going to sound creepy one of my
favorite things in the world is when you
sit down on a toilet and someone had
just gotten off it and it's still warm
i
love it
love it it makes me embrace humanity
like we're still people that love each
other i go i go dude someone was just
here it's like when you're when you're
uh tracking an animal and you see a paw
print you're like oh wow he's around
here like you remember when you're a kid
you found like coyote [ __ ] you're like
dude there's an animal in these woods
it's like when you sit down on toilet
you're like oh it's still warm
i can smell his cologne
would you rather be an awesome nfl
kicker or an average nfl tight end
awesome nfl kicker without a [ __ ]
doubt yes and i would drink and i would
do drugs i would be and i would just
[ __ ]
i'm ready for that moment i want
here's here's my reasoning it's thank
you you're an fsu guys you're just being
sebastian
i didn't say his name because i was like
i wonder if he if he's like uh i'm
trying to do a polish accent he's like
oh i know that boy
and then he watches it and he's like oh
i've cleaned my opt up um
uh
here's what i want you ready here's my
logic here's why i want to be an nfl
kicker
if you're an average tight end
you don't get that much excitement but
when you're a kicker you get that moment
you get that moment where the game
depends on you you have 50 000 people
watching you you get to sit there and go
all right
what am i made of and you take your
steps and you go let's [ __ ] do i love
that feeling that moment when they kick
and they kind of stand there and they're
like yeah yeah going in and everyone i
love my favorite one of my favorite
feelings ever uh i did secret time we
did two shows in philly first show i
bombed i bombed and i was like [ __ ] now
i have always said i like pressure my
favorite thing in the world is pressure
uh we get up in the to the thing we have
one more show and leanne's like what
we're about to find out how much you
like pressure i go what she's like he
got one show big guy and i was like [ __ ]
oh
to [ __ ] split the uprights i mean
secret times i'm that murdered that's
that was the best set of comedy i'd ever
done in my life it was like so tight so
dialed in and at one point
uh they were stomping on the ground so
hard i had a joke about uh go to your
refrigerator pull out a diet coke and
you get to the i get to the school and i
take a sip and realize i have a coors
light i go that's when you find out what
man you are what kind of guy are you guy
in the orgy that gets a finger and asks
and pulls away or you guys pushes back
in and they [ __ ] were stomping and i
was like i was like i could just feel
myself like lining up and going here we
go
and you just had contact you're like i
made good contact we're watching it soar
i want that feeling i want that feeling
i would i would actually train to become
an nfl kicker just to get that feeling
what is your stance on washing your
hands after you piss
i don't do it
[Laughter]
my dick is clean it's an old joke but
will smith said this to me he didn't
wash his hands after he pisses either
shout out to will smith
he i said to him i we were leaving the
abc bathroom and we both took a piss
together this is 24 years ago and
he had he
came up to piss next to me and i got gun
shy right i got gun shy and i couldn't
piss because he has a huge [ __ ] and he
has a fire hose of urine coming out and
he's just pissing next to me and he's
going let me tell you the key to
hollywood let me tell you the key to
this business and i can't hear anything
because all i'm thinking is just start
pissing just start pissing but i can't
because this is so loud and i have a
dribble of a piss and i have to piss so
[ __ ] bad and then finally i go [ __ ]
if i'm going to sell a tv show next to
this man i better learn how to piss next
to this man so i just push push and i
start pissing and all i hear him saying
his advice is uh is uh
is um
be yourself that's it that's it
and then
and then he goes over to the sink and he
sits on the sink and he's just waiting
for me to done get pissed and he just
goes man you're taking a long piss i was
like i just started
so i get done
and i don't wash my hands and i turn
around i go and i think it's a root of
connection and i go hey you don't wash
your hands after your piss i don't wash
my hands after a piss he goes my dick's
clean let's go and we walked into a room
and sold a tv show
my deck's clean let's go
bert once again crushed answer the
internet if you want to watch our
two-hour interview with them where we
show each other our balls and have a
long ball off and where we have a
[ __ ] giving competition subscribe and
click here